federal agents with an urgent warning to
parents about rainbow fentanyl Hills the
colors of candy this is every parents
worst nightmare as Halloween fast
approaches are evil drug dealers trying
to poison your kids with rainbow fenel
this Halloween Horror Story needs a fact
check last year the DEA warned that
colorful pills were a deliberate effort
by drug traffickers to drive addiction
amongst kids cops journalists and even
Congressmen have insisted that rainbow f
is designed to lure innocent kids into a
life of addiction fenel might be the
latest scare but this isn't new and it's
obvious that like the others this story
is for dumb Dums why would drug dealers
give their products away for free
especially to kids kids don't even have
their own money the truth is much less
Sensational suppliers color their pills
to distinguish their product like
Heisenberg's blue meth from Breaking Bad
this story is about as real as
werewolves and vampires